this is the ingram angle from washington
tonight the biden justice department is
getting so desperate
they've now gone nuclear the angle will
explain in moments plus when fbi agents
swept into mar-a-lago on monday they
were met by president trump's attorney
christina bob she's here in moments with
her response to merrick garland and to
update us on whether the trump team
will allow the warrant to be unsealed
ahead of tomorrow's deadline but first
spin cycle crash that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
now can you imagine what president xi is
thinking right now
how about putin or the terrorists who
hope to strike against american
interests
this is the america they used to fear
i personally approved the decision to
seek a search warrant in this matter
faithful adherence to the rule of law is
the bedrock principle of the justice
department and of our democracy
upholding the rule of law means applying
the law evenly without fear or favor
under my watch that is precisely what
the justice department is doing
doesn't he look like a guy who just got
a lot of wedgies in like sixth grade i'm
sorry i'm gonna be forever grateful to
mitch mcconnell for keeping that
apparatchik off the court
today he said a lot of nothing he
changed no minds about the propriety of
this raid not a single one
now what we've witnessed this week
including today's five minutes of
nothing is a sham it's a total
embarrassment for america
now putting trump in the vice of the
current president's fbi is what you'd
expect from russia's fsb
not a proud constitutional republic
the signal to the world is unmistakable
our 246 year old republic is being
pulled apart at the seams so dictators
can now say look we told you this entire
democracy thing was a scam
turns out their president can try to put
his political critics in jail just like
we do
now our president who traditionally is
known as the leader of the free world
has become a laughingstock
so afraid of his political nemesis
that it let it be known to his doj goons
that they needed to finish off trump
politically for good
now remember as we told you on monday it
was last spring that biden's people used
their stenographers at the new york
times to pass word onto garland
they reported that biden privately
complained that he wanted garland to act
more like a prosecutor when it came to
trump in january 6.
well message received
biden and the doj have now totally lost
control of this narrative
after that dramatic monday raid they
were they were positively shocked and
stunned to see republicans closing ranks
something they rarely do
against this unprecedented heavy-handed
tactics
a back and forth over documents the
president's team padlocking a storage
room at the government's request and
then
they show up months later to rummage
around for nine hours
now respected figures in the gop with
varied and long political resumes
objected strenuously to the type of
targeting of trump that we saw everyone
from the former vice president to the
former director of the cia and secretary
of state to senators marco rubio and
chuck grassley
now everyone
including merrick garland and
christopher wray
they know that this group
isn't necessarily a trump fan club
for them all to speak out almost in
unison
is a disaster for the democrats
so in a perpetual spin cycle the doj is
apparently now petitioning that sketchy
magistrate bruce rinehart to release the
search warrant and the property received
we'll see what we see there when it
comes out
but in the absence of actual facts
all we have are a bunch of unverifiable
claims popping out about moles inside
mar-a-lago earlier today it was
reporting that perhaps it was a secret
service agent working on trump's detail
and then late tonight the you know new
doj
information it looks like they laundered
their latest justification through the
washington post
that fbi agents were scouring trump's
residence in search of nuclear documents
now that could mean anything right it
could be a print out from the nuclear
regulatory agency or the department of
energy it could be an email whatever
and if that's the excuse that they want
to run with for this raid
how could they possibly justify letting
hillary clinton off the hook when she
was holding documents that were
classified at the highest levels
so i guess we're supposed to believe
that established the probable cause that
was necessary for the search warrant
this nuclear deal
just like we're supposed to believe that
merritt garland hadn't approved of the
raid at all remember they tried to spin
that
that was the lie that they spread last
night in newsweek try to keep up with me
here
oh sorry gentlemen but
given your history with president trump
and the american people you're going to
have to do better than just trust us we
believe in the rule of law
the fact that our cia our fbi and our
doj
have lost most of their credibility
let me tell you it's not fox news's
fault
it's not the fault of trump or his
supporters
they didn't create garland's problem or
comey's problem or ray's problem or
andrew mckay's problem
they've all brought this on themselves
so no matter what garland or rey may say
it's not normal to weaponize the entire
power of the federal government against
one individual
in this case trying to find any
technical charge they can to bring
against president trump
all of course just months before he'll
likely announce another white house run
how convenient
how will the democrats react let's say
if the next republican president
pulled these same tactics to dig into
let's say kamala harris's life or gavin
newsom's life
well we all know the answer right they'd
cry foul and claim that that president
and his doj was subverting democracy
so the standard going forward has to be
that administrations will only pursue
legally their opponent
when it's a really big bleeping deal
no dragnets no fishing expeditions no
protectual searches no desperate
trolling for moles
some or all of this may have happened
here
the chance of lock her up remember those
during all the trump rallies in 2016
they were just that they were chance
chance designed to mock hillary and the
sycophantic press that covered for her
trump and millions of his supporters
were furious that mrs clinton seemed to
use her office to advance her husband's
foundation
yet even when they believed all that
did trump after he was elected send fbi
agents to her house
of course not
because his focus was on making our
country better more prosperous
but now now we have an administration
that's decided to go to war against all
of us
they have unlimited government resources
at their disposal and they're deploying
them against trump and they're about to
hire 80 south 7 000 new irs agents to
deploy against anyone who questions them
well i have news for them
the constitution gets to say who runs
for president not merrick garland
hunting trump will only hurt them
now at a time when our families are
facing
such daunting challenges it just makes
you want to burst out in tears
where's biden's focus and passion
it's not fixing any of this it's on
grabbing as much power from the regular
people as he can
do they care that wages really aren't
keeping up with inflation not even close
which means that our people are getting
poorer every week and every month
no they don't care about that
they just spend fairy tales
zero inflation last month but people are
still hurting
but zero inflation last month that last
month our economy had zero percent
inflation
in july
we saw a drop in gas prices and a range
of other goods like clothing and
airfares and household appliances which
means
more money in the pockets of working
families our goal and we think it is
absolutely possible is to is to have
this economy transition
spin cycle crash
americans don't trust the government
because they're bad people
we don't trust the government because
they aren't proving worthy of our trust
stop treating americans from the other
party with suspicion stop pretending
that you believe in borders and start
enforcing them
stop lying about the true state of our
economy you just heard it
and stop wish casting about what's
happening in ukraine
stop lying about the innate character of
america our system is not racist you are
and finally announce publicly that
you're dropping all of this legal
harassment of president trump
and then president biden go before the
cameras
and tell our country that any disputes
between you and trump
are going to be decided by the voters
in 2024
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else